head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
well I'll tell you I just checked
Crowders got 300
000 live viewers yeah that means I mean
compare him to The Young Turks sorry
look I'm not trying to be mean to The
Young Turks but 12 000. so so we've got
74 000 we're a talk show we're not I
think you know he's probably got a
bigger crew he does this stuff better
than we do so he's also doing it on
Rumble too so right like isn't he isn't
his own rubble's smaller than YouTube
yeah but so it's like all the people
that prefer Rumble are just going
straight to him though too it's not it's
not this first not that I'm denigrated
hold on hold on bannon's got 65 000
viewers we have a fries got 18 000
ricadas got 10K Charlie Cook's at 62. so
it's not there's a rumble is very very
active YouTube I think is starting to
realize that they've been shooting
themselves in the foot by with their
policies yo think about this they gave
Crowder a strike so that he would not or
or for whatever reason but now he
because of it he couldn't be on YouTube
so rumble's getting all of that traffic
that has to be one of the worst business
decisions you've ever made for what The
Young Turks The Young Turks look I'm not
trying to be a dick to Jack but they've
got like 10 12K viewers and they're
doing midterm coverage they're a
featured Channel when you buy YouTube TV
this is what we use on all our TVs for
Digital streaming I get YouTube TV and
The Young Turks is a channel just like
Fox News and they're only getting 12K
this is what YouTube deserves they
deserve to lose in their business for
for the for the dirty games they play so
what does Chris pavlovski have to do to
take it over the top to get Rumble to
that next level do you think well the
challenge is one of the reasons a lot of
these shows are doing really well right
now in Rumble is Rumble is overtly
political refugees they really need to I
think focus on attracting apolitical
Talent comedy entertainment and shows
but it seems like their big strategy was
to go to podcasters and you know
political commentary and it's like it's
good you know politics is pop culture
right now so it's a smart move but you
need something wider than that that's
why c will do it just went over there
yeah band well there you go I mean but
there's people there right so we have
300 000 Subs on on our timcast IRL
Rumble Channel and uh my personal
Channel and then I got another Channel
70k but we just moved everything to one
Consolidated and I look at some of the
videos and they get between five and ten
thousand views a lot less than what I
get on YouTube I get 200 to 300
sometimes even 500 how about the one you
do with during beady
yeah that that was that was uh taken off
of YouTube for uh censorship reasons and
it was put onto Rumble where it got like
2.3 million which I believe was our
biggest podcast until we did Alex Jones
and Joe Rogan why did you get so many
with Darren do you think on Rumble
that's from Darren Beatty from
revolver.news if anyone's curious why do
you think that you can promote any he
promoted it yeah you think that was the
big reason that it popped on two two
reasons one was that Darren Beatty
promoted the show saying you know
censorship is impacting us and uh that
factor of like the show was taken down
we want to see it so I think the big
thing holding back Rumble is that if and
this is just personal opinion I'm not an
expert on this but I feel like that they
just made it look more like YouTube as
close as they could get it to YouTube
without being YouTube and having maybe a
legal problem because do you guys even
know what is a rumble like I can't even
figure this out I've been around like
when it says you have like a thousand
rumbles yeah it's like you have this
many likes and so you don't know what a
rumble is I don't know what a rumble is
does anybody here know what a rumble is
no it's like an upvote almost it's a
boat
I think it might be like a link share or
something I don't know okay I think
they're calling uh they're calling Texas
for Apple yeah it looks like beta went
down yeah they don't Beto lost yeah this
can't be accurate no way isn't this like
this people don't want to be disarmed
people don't want government controlling
every aspect of their lives heck yeah
people just don't want him they just
don't want him people don't want open
borders in Texas what by the way Tim
Vermont's still blue
Vermont is still blue yeah like it was
blue I don't know what you were looking
at but no the governor race on Reuters
has Vermont called for the Republican oh
really yeah it was 16 reporting wait
Vermont Vermont yeah wait is that
surprising Governor Phil Scott
Republican
it says he's the incumbent hey there's
your free state project it's just right
now no that's that's New Hampshire yeah
pay attention I know but I'm just saying
just saying for governor right you could
just what are you looking right next
door
legalized heroin and everything in
Vermont isn't that what they have
um no it's not hilarious I don't think
they have legalized here really all
right New Hampshire Governor they're
calling it for Chris but that's New
Hampshire Vermont I don't yeah Phil
Scott was the Republican incumbent
Governor from Vermont so them going
Republican is not that surprising yeah
yeah I thought it was the
Ohio is now leaning towards JD Vance
with 45 in so that's that's he's up by
uh point six point six percent I thought
it was interesting he got a Tulsi
gabbard's endorsement that was cool yeah
and it's looking like the big cities are
mostly in well okay no that's not so
much but we'll see 31 41 Dayton's at 44
so we'll see
will be interesting to say the least but
yep is that what we're hearing that uh
they called it for for Abbott Beto's out
yeah that's what it's looking like news
Nation called it for sure fetterman has
taken an early lead on odds that's
something well I guess is it
Philadelphia and Pittsburgh so
Philadelphia has a lot in already
they were saying that Philadelphia was
going to hold back a bunch of ballots
right weren't they saying that yes but
um they I think it was like 83 in and
they it leans very heavy
that I mean it's usually it's like 95 of
the vote there yeah yeah yeah so even if
it is I mean that's still a win in
Philly I think if you get like 80 if
it's only 80 percent
why do you guys think a guy as talented
as Dr Oz couldn't take on
um fetterman because Federman put a
billboard up during the Eagles game that
said Oz is a Oz is a Giants fan not a
Giants fan of Dallas fan that's why
that's what he did no he really did it
was like genius and everybody was
calling it on a stupid but every anybody
that likes any Philly sports would tell
you that that was like why did they run
Beto and Stacy Abrams I don't know
they're like these people are losers
let's run them they lost last time so
they're doing it again they have though
like honestly
I mean it's pretty interesting like
they're most of the political Talent
right now I think is on the conservative
side there are some talented politicians
on the uh on the Democratic side like I
think you know I think Tim you and I
maybe disagree with this but I think AOC
is pretty charismatic and relatively
talented as a politician she keeps
winning you think I disagree with you on
that do you did you disagree with me on
that no I feel like we disagreed on that
like maybe a year ago maybe maybe it was
somebody else
I just got an image academically Smart
Way
from the conversation about who's next I
just got an image of the democratic
party going around intensive care units
in the hospital and nursing homes to be
like who else are we going to get who
else can we pick here please we need
somebody to please represent us so you
could be the empty shell that of course
pushes the great reset agendas and of
course screws everyone over let me tell
you what really what what grinds my
gears y'all right now 36 of expected
votes are be have been counted and
that's 45
000 for Alexandria ocasio-cortez and
only 14 206 for Tina Forte
and that means that AOC will have won
the seat of congress with about a
hundred and thirty hundred thirty five
thousand votes in a district of 770
000 in a district with an estimated 180
000 conservatives or Republicans
so if there was maximum GOP turnout a
republican would have won um
people don't vote and you know
conservatives don't really think either
they don't go there and tell people to
vote because they don't think it's worth
it and then you get these days for sure
with the zeldin campaign right like I
know for months some of the some of the
journalists that I know in New York were
like why isn't anyone covering zeldon
they would pitch stories on zeldon and
outlets and be like eh he doesn't have a
chance and they wouldn't take the
stories
it was only recently it was only within
like the past month that anyone was
willing to run zelding zeldon content
I'm feeling confident on on balduck but
we'll see we have a bunch of we have uh
Manchester Portsmouth and Concord are
reporting and then a bunch of the more
rural areas uh less so but there are a
lot of blue ones so uh you know we'll
see we'll see
we will see man I I'd be interested to
see Portsmouth is so expensive like I
was looking at apartments there at one
point and it was like I may as well just
move to Manhattan it's a no difference
yeah oh and you've been all around the
United States you work with people
one-on-one individually what do you
think is the cause the issue that people
care about the most is it the economy is
it crime what do you see with the pulse
of this country and and where it's going
I think where it's going it's going to
be economic yeah the the economy thing
is terrifying actually yeah you know it
should be for anyone paying attention I
think it should be but I think I mean
maybe I'm stuck in like lives of tick
tock world but I definitely think that
it's the gender stuff I mean even when I
talk to people on the street that's all
they're talking about I think it's good
it's gone too it's going to become
economic if we go into a downturn hmm
and I think it's pretty clear we're
heading towards uh potentially some very
bad times financially potential not for
sure potential it could be very I think
the writing's on the wall I I think it's
pretty clear when when you print so much
money when you have such Reckless
policies that prioritize the ESG over
you know capitalism and freedom when you
have so many subsidies when you have so
much finagling by the by the
multinational corporations essentially
running governments and allowing them to
do what they want when you have such out
of control Financial policies I think
it's only headed down One Direction what
happened in 2008 was a warning shot and
it was something that we should have
taken seriously we should have let big
businesses and big Banks fail we never
did we paved over a big bubble with a
bigger bubble and I think that bubble is
you know going to pop eventually when
it's going to pop I don't know but I
think a lot of people are are fearing it
I think it's looming I think it's there
and I think there's no way we could
ignore the elephant in the room when it
comes to the larger Financial
ramifications of these Reckless policies
that have brought us here yeah the 2008
and we sold out American Youth in favor
of pumping up big businesses it was
really a crime yeah the Federal Reserve
we need Ian in here the Federal Reserve
Ian we were talking about it Luke do you
think that it was deliberate that they
printed that much money
um I mean it doesn't make any sense I I
remember talking to Ben Bernanke after
2008 and I actually snuck in with Paul
volcker and got into this private VIP
area and I saw Ben Bernanke sitting
there and I walked up to him with my
microphone and I was like Mr Bernanke
how does it feel engineering one of the
world's largest secretive Banker
bailouts to some of the biggest
International Banks all over the world
that no one even knows about it
he got so flustered he got so pissed off
he grabbed my microphone and tried to
literally steal it out of my head and
was up in arms calling and screaming for
security people don't know about the
secret bailouts in 2008. those secret
bailouts were still going on and
probably still are going on right now
during covid they will have grave
implications on our entire economic
system and then when he got really
uncomfortable when security came they
had to literally pick me up lift me lift
me out of there and I was like okay we
could talk about Bilderberg if that's
another topic that you want to discuss
here he got even more mad because this
was my third confrontation with him
where we got face to face and we're
screaming at each other those old videos
that you posted are some of the most
insane things I've ever seen on the
internet they were fun they were very
excited so yeah and this is really crazy
because
Luke is the guy who just went and did it
yeah he just walked up to these people
asking questions he just hopped on about
what tapstein island and started filming
everything it's about persistence you
want something you could get it in life
if you really you know put if you were
on Epstein Island oh God
I love it I'm just like I go like this
is Luke uh he's been to Epstein Island I
don't want to go uh uh yeah
I'm not Bill Clinton I'm not a pervial
okay but you were there yes I did go to
episode I have to talk later
I wasn't invited I wasn't invited I I
crashed it and the video is completely
insane how do you crash you take a boat
and you and you go there I would have
done that and I started searching and I
started searching for tunnels it's like
where's the tunnels where's all the
hidden by the tunnel I found a door that
goes into the ground on top of the the
biggest hill there but it's a huge area
it's it's I I was running throughout the
whole space and I only got to see half
of it is that creepy Castle thing fake
no it's real it's painted yeah uh so it
looks uh like it's a like it's a big
castle but but no it's real it's up
there but the the walls were reported up
I was trying to get in there I was
trying to rip it apart
um it didn't have the tools I used to
legit worry about you bro thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time